now to the Netflix and spill that we all
expected from Harry and Megan's Netflix
stocking series but I do not think we
expected all the drama to start at the
disclaimer yeah the big question today
was the royal family contacted for this
docu-series like Harry and Megan claim
well we do know this today King Charles
he just kept calm and carried on
destroy
there is a huge level of unconscious
bias
a way to the Press was King Charles's
only response just hours after the first
three episodes dropped will they watch
the docu-series my understanding is that
the Royals suddenly the king of the
queen consorts will not be watching the
donkey series and William and Kate they
were on the school run today I think
there's a sense of weariness and fatigue
at hearing this story solely through the
mouthpieces of Harry and Megan
to say but was the royal family reached
for comment At All by the docu-series
at the start of Harry and Megan this
disclaimer reads quote the royal family
declined to comment but ET has learned
it's not the full picture the palace
received an email from a third party
asking for comment the palace then tried
to verify the authenticity of this email
by contacting Netflix and archworld and
there is we understand no response
therefore that is why the Palaces said
they didn't have an opportunity to
comment
congratulations to you both thank you in
your engagement interview
um
orchestrated reality show yeah
but it was you know rehearsed how do you
think the royal family is portrayed in
this certainly the royal family don't
come out as the glowing modern positive
upbeat institution will and Kate came
over Rosen ripped jeans and I was
barefoot it's like I was a hugger I've
always been a hugger I didn't realize
that that is really a
jarring for a lot of Breads and that was
surprising to me I think our suspicions
about this being a pretty cool
relationship right from the start have
have been confirmed here and I think it
also confirms what we've always known
which is that Megan and Kate are two
very very different women and it's not
natural for her to go and give a great
big bear hug to someone that she hasn't
met before so again I think those sort
of cultural clashes we're clearly there
[Music]